[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to an update on
the red
hydrogen one
this thing is so delayed it's silly but
you might remember it from that
exclusive reveal video which was back in
august 2017 so about a year ago the
update is a couple weeks ago they sent
out an email asking basically to every
pre-order if they wanted to participate
in the houdini program which was
basically a sort of a beta testing or
prototype testing where they'd send you
one early and you'd sort of get to bug
report and help them build this phone as
they go which is really interesting i
don't think i've seen anything quite
like that from a phone in a while then
again
it's red this is a camera company that i
think right now is discovering slowly
how hard it is to build a good
smartphone in this really competitive
landscape and i think generally their
development has been much slower than
the competition but this is it this is
one of the limited edition red hydrogen
one houdini edition phones that will be
made and shipped to those people who
agreed to be a part of it without any
further ado let's go ahead and look in
the box
so this is it uh it comes in this all
black uh cardboard unlabeled box it's
kind of matte black but not really also
excuse the bandage i don't think you
really want to see the stitches in my
finger right now it's a long story but
we can get right into it if we open it
at the top of this first box we get a
little card that says inside this box
you'll find an unlocked hydrogen 1
limited edition houdini model plus 128
gig micro sd card and an extended
warranty at no charge nice and then
that's this so this is a little red and
black micro sd card since the phone has
expandable storage and then we have this
glass and metal
uh i don't really know what this is
honestly it says red medium machine
hydrogen
it's like a medallion it's kind of like
a souvenir i guess that maybe you could
stick to your desk or a computer or
something it's not really clear what to
do with it but it's high quality so i'll
keep it around cool anyway underneath
that we get the labeled box with the
phone in it it's packaged actually
pretty similar to a lot of other red
products i don't know if you've ever
unboxed a red accessory or even a red
camera or something like that you'll
probably be familiar with these boxes
with the magnets and everything it's
high quality so i'm a fan of that we
open this up and we have the phone right
up top hydrogen
and we'll go ahead and and get that
plastic off in a second but we also want
to see what else is in the box we do
have some paperwork at the top is this
sort of a quick start guide which shows
you how to get the phone up and running
getting a sim card in there and
everything like that underneath that
there's your important safety
information and that warranty
and under that there's actually a red
branded power brick and usb type-c cable
it says on the brick it's five volts
three amps so we'll cross our fingers
for some type of quick charging
happening here
but that's that
so right off the bat
this is like my second impression and
yeah the phone is still big it's still
so huge you can probably tell even in my
hands it looks like a massive device it
still has those pins on the back which
is interesting
the ridges the huge grips up and down
the bezels
a lot of cutouts for front-facing
sensors actually
and it's just overall a unique looking
phone it doesn't even have it doesn't
have the normal sleek and modern look of
all the other glass sandwich flagships
we've gotten lately it just looks kind
of like another red camera like a tool
or a device you'd use for a function and
that's it we'll go ahead and get it
booted for the first time with this
power button fingerprint reader on the
side
and this loading animation this one
right here is the first time i'm seeing
this holographic effect right off the
bat
and it definitely does not pick up on
camera it just looks slanted
but then after it sets up it it just
runs sets up like a normal android phone
i registered my fingerprint signed in
with google and everything
so now i'm really gonna just start
digging into this thing and seeing what
it's all about this is day one for me
and you already know i'm gonna be
sharing my thoughts on it as we go and
you better believe i'm also gonna be
tweeting sample photos from that camera
that's the main thing i'm into so be
sure to be following there if you're not
already
and we got to start digging through this
thing and seeing what it's all about
there is of course a lot of concern over
how delayed this thing is naturally
because it has last year's specs from
when it got announced so for those who
forgot snapdragon 835 six gigs of ram
but also a 4 000 milliamp hour battery
and expandable storage i think a lot of
people who pre-ordered this phone though
aren't buying it to use as their primary
phone at least i don't think like i
think it's got to be a lot of people
like me who want this to be an
absolutely baller camera experience
first
and then also have a great software
experience kind of like a phone you know
but there is a lot happening here
there's a separate marketplace for apps
and games that support the holographic
four view content in addition to the
play store
there is of course this red launcher
which you can disable and use the normal
android launcher but that's definitely
worth exploring also there's also this
really interesting camera app with a lot
of controls at your fingertips and i've
been told they're still working on the
app
on the controls you have the image
processing the color science all of that
but they're going to use our experience
with these prototypes to keep improving
it as we go the holographic display
itself it doesn't show up basically at
all on camera it just kind of looks like
normal content that's pixelated because
of how the tech works but in person
on this near final version it's really
trippy and it definitely
it's going to be a challenge to shoot
stuff
and and actually take advantage of the
holographic nature of it to make it look
good there's some demo reels and some
things where stuff pops out at the
camera and some of it looks good but
that's going to be a challenge and
there's even little things i'm seeing
like one of these little cutouts up
front is a multi-color notification led
and this exact model here i'm holding is
serial number triple zero eight of the
uh 300 prototypes they're gonna be
making so that's pretty cool and i've
also noticed it seems like it's really
easy for dust and stuff to get caught in
these little grooves on the back of the
phone we'll see if that holds up and the
dual cameras and the flash module on the
back look exactly like a face and
there's much much more but definitely
let me know what you think about the
whole hydrogen one concept one year
later basically there's still a lot we
don't know there's still the exposed
pins on the back we don't know what the
modules look like but just the whole
idea of like this huge phone that's i
guess a camera first and then a phone
second and then the rest of the things
that connect to it and let me know what
you want to see in a full review for
when that comes out either way thanks
for watching catch you in the next one
peace